cantona moufles rice a fait pendant des
semaines de kirk se sourit tout ça parce
qu'ils s'aiment à paris
au printemps
sur les toits les girouettes et tourné
pour les coquettes avec le premier vent
qui passe indifférent le chaland
[Applaudissements]
car
quand elle vient à paris n'a plus qu'un
seul souci c'est d'aller lui janine
homps tourner vos quartiers de paris
le soleil
qui est sous deux copains et aussi de la
fête et comme de plaisir il s'en prend
aux quais de paris
et la main dans la main les six ans mais
regardant son chemin si paris a changé
ya toujours
des taxis en maraude qui vous charge
tant fraude avons le stationnement
rayons comme l'agent des toxines
au café
envoie n'importe qui qui boit n'importe
quoi qui parle avec ses mains qui est là
depuis le matin au café
il
n'importe quelle heure elle ces
militaires qui la regardent dans les
yeux ce sont ces amoureux à la c
il ya ceux
ceux qui ont fait leur lit près du lit
de la scène et qui cela va me dis tous
les jours de la semaine dans la seine
et les auteurs
ce qui à lanta c'est parce qu'ils en ont
vu trop et qui veulent tout oublié alors
il jette à l'eau mais la scène
elle préfère
revoir les jolis bateaux se promener sur
elle et au fil de son no jouer aux
caravelles sur la scène
les produits
y'en a pas qu'à paris à me sens monde
entier oui mais tant le monde entier il
n'y a pas partout paris lalande
apparaît
au 14 juillet à la ferme et lampions
dans ce sens à terre son de l'accordéon
dans les rues
depuis qu'à paris on a beau dire
pastilles lanchettes bourrache et que
d'harcourt
dégâts et
qui sans apprêt sur les pavés lui tous
les jours pour des tours et détours pas
paris
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]